all right so you've made commits you
understand that a commit ID is a big
deal and now we're going to talk about a
2-step commit why you have to use get
add and get commit now remember when we
make a commit ID that is pretty
permanent right that's in history so
this section over here is our log of
commits it's like a story of all of the
changes you've made to put together your
codebase but first we have to get there
right so you're working locally and you
make some changes say you make changes
to an index.html and to a CSS file but
you don't really want those to be stored
together the changes that you made were
not logically related in any way that's
okay that's what get ad is for get lets
you choose exactly which files you want
to include in the next commit so let's
say we want to do the index first so
we'll get add index.html and it'll move
that file and get some metadata to the
staging area get knows that when you run
git commit only to include the index
file not the CSS file so any files in
the working directory if you want them
to be included in the commit you need to
use git add first once they're in the
staging area gets going to include them
in the next commit once you run git
commit and then all of those files that
snapshot of the repository including
your changes are stored with that 40
character sha-1 hash in history